another spectacular night in the motor
city on this wednesday night we get
ready for first pitch willie
off the il for the tigers on the mound
tonight
another breaking ball and harrison
reaches out pokes it into center field
for a base hit so josh harrison spoiled
the breaking ball before that
that one had a little bit more of the
plate he was out in front a little bit
but still managed to get a base hit to
center feet 0-1 to matt olson
and the pick off throw he gets thrown
away
harrison's gonna go to second and now
he's gonna try for third
and he's gonna make it what happens is
this ball
ends up carrying instead of bouncing off
it shoots up
the line towards right field and now
matt olsen needs to put it in play
and he does he smokes one toward right
grossman
diving catch he comes up with it throws
it back in but harrison's gonna score
so grossman with a nice play but it's
going to be a sacrifice fly olson does
his job and the a's have an early
one-nothing lead james caprilian will be
taking on the detroit tigers making his
18th start of the season
right there strike three called badou
took it and that is
out number one
and this one is driven to left going
back room is kemp in front of the wall
and he makes the catch
so that's how the bottom of the first
ends
the 2-2
sent to left center field
long run for martay and that's going to
hit off the wall
[Applause]
jamer candelario a doubles hitting
machine
leads off the second with a double speed
just going away from looking at the
weights lead off double tigers a good
opportunity to tie it up here loss was
one for four last night he was the dh
last night tonight he's catching he goes
after the first pitch and hits one well
to right cannas back cannon near the
wall and he jumps up up against the wall
and he makes the catch
candelario alertly tags and goes to
third trying to go to right great field
doesn't want to pull off it just missed
it field is in against harold castro
the other way and a base hit for harold
castro to tie the ball game at one
lead up though get him over get him in
it gets wide open all you got to do is
put it in place
here comes derek hill to the plate yeah
that'd be beautiful
matt chapman steals extra bases away
from derek hill on the first pitch in
the tigers third all right man in the
right spot they call it the hot corner
for a reason
see how he stays low and doesn't pop up
he'll go into his great
pre-pitch routine and that right there
plays as much a part in matt chapman
being able to make that play as his
athleticism
that one is hit deep left center field
and that baby's gone marty gives the a's
a two to one lead he got a hanger into
the shrubbery kite no over swing just a
hang you know what happens when you hang
them they bang them pack your bags mr
marte all aboard next stop pound town
switch hitter batting from the left side
also the first base with one out
and he smokes one center field that's
hit well hill going back hill still
going back it's over his head
he picks it up rounding third is olson
he's going to come in to score a booming
rbi double by lowry and it's three to
one the a's lead how about jed lowry
just dropping the head down and in
derrick hill had a great shot at this
ball off the bat he was tracking it very
nicely just continued to carry miguel
cabrera batting well there we go there's
a bullet left field gone we're tied at
three
cabrera belts number 502
that was a no doubter everybody talk
about a hangar goodbye
goodbye miggy got it the tigers have two
on and two out he'll line hard to third
his first time
runners go and it's
hit in the air right center marte's back
and martay has it the a's have started
the fifth with back-to-back singles
here's olson a sac fly to walk
3-2 pitch is drill to center
hustling back still going back and it's
over the head of derek hill
one runs going to score marte is racing
around he
will score
and olson has come through again
a two-run double over the center
fielder's head and the a's grab the lead
back five to three well a great piece of
hitting by matt olson got himself a
sinker he was able to drive just right
back over the heart of the plate here's
jed switch hitter batting left
and he drives one right center field
forget about it nobody's gonna get it
deep part of the ballpark olson scores
lowry has another rbi double and the a's
are just teeing off on irania he's
throwing the ball right down the middle
judd lowry with authority 6-3 bottom of
the fifth inning will be at the top of
the order another 3-2
down to right field and god that got out
of here quickly
akil badu with his 11th of the season a
solo shot to lead off the fifth
one there default got in on him and he
got here quick he got on top of that
excellent castro
now fly ball left center field this
one's deep attracting hit camp he's
going back and that ball's gone wow just
kept going and the tigers are within one
step with that front foot he got those
arms back and he really drove through
this ball to left center field
first two men aboard for the tigers here
in the seventh so now jonathan scope two
two to scope
ground ball base hit left side hill's
got wheels he will score standing up and
jonathan skulk has tied it up trying to
throw that slider down and into jonathan
scope left that over the plate
[Applause]
five cents oh derrick hill is gone
look how quick he gets around
first pitch to miguel swing the line
drive softly into center it's going to
drop for a base hit badou didn't read it
he's going to get home though joe goes
to second scope slides in the head of
the throw little flare dropped in front
of martin the tigers take a 7-6 lead
here in the seventh we got a pitch it
looked like right down the heart of the
plane and the big man put a good buggy
whip on that baby to drive in the run
that leaves it up to a kill purdue
to the left side great piece of hitting
by akil badu he delivers another run and
the tigers are up too
gregory soto is on for the tigers ninth
faces jan gomes who's pinch hitting for
elvis andrews now the one two
chased upstairs and he sits him down
that's the express there huh
up top no chance two outs in the ninth
inning that leaves it up to starling
marty he's a good slider here barry at
the dirt the one two
that's the series equalizer
first win for the tigers over the a's at
comerica park since april 28
of 2016.